he's gonna be much more forthcoming
because he's in the patient chair and
I'm so used to be I'll probably be
asking you questions so what do you
recommend to others embarking on a
creative partnership what selection
process do you recommend - putting a
potential partner through like is there
a litmus test here in Hollywood well I
don't know what the well I'm sorry to me
please know the I don't think there's a
litmus test because I've known I've
known people from my dad my dad's
generation down to you know my
generation and much younger people and
there's all kinds of partnerships for me
I have a litmus test after having a
number of failed partnerships and a
couple of really good ones and that is
that the person should have
complementary skills not the same skills
I think there's no point in a
partnership where both people can do the
exact same thing equally well you might
as well be riding alone and getting more
money for it because the one thing that
I tell students is be prepared to split
your paycheck but on the other hand they
love partnerships in this town they
particularly love male-female
partnerships because they think they're
getting two sides of the brain which
they may very well be but yeah for me
that's my litmus test if I have one but
it's it's not anything I've really
thought about until we started working
together seven years ago I had a
longtime writing partner who was great
with with jokes and she was great with
because she came out of stand not of
stand-up so much as she worked in the
Kentucky Fried theatre which was the
Abrams sucker brothers before they made
airplane they had a theater out here and
she was great joke writer and a pretty
good dialogue writer and had been an
actress and I was a story guy
so that was complementary skills it
worked I think it's it's kind of like if
both people are great at jokes and
they're not good at story I don't think
that's such a good partnership what do
you think okay good
and let's see the idea of picking a
partner I mean I've had a lot of writing
partners as well and what what I'm
stunned at is how long it takes till you
figure out if you're in a good
partnership or not you know there's a
the idea of first impressions people are
on really good behavior when they first
meet you they're very compliant they're
very complimentary and then eventually
you get to peel away layers and see how
they are if you can really work with
them that I was so cranky that first
night that oh I mean we we decided to
work together the day we met which was
do you want tell story no because I so
enjoy you telling the story did you see
his nose girl um I was one flight above
he was in his car our kids were playing
together they were both in the same 8th
grade class having a playdate Jeffrey
was sitting in his car crankily waiting
for his son to come down on time because
he didn't want to come upstairs and meet
yet another parent you have to go
through hi my name is what do you do
yeah and of course the kid wouldn't come
so he comes up and we went through the
hi how are you and when we get into that
part it's oh you're an academic so am I
and then Jeffrey said you know I've been
a writer about all my life but now they
expect me to do academic writing do you
do any of that hey I'm starting a long
boring research background so I said
yeah I've done a lot of that and I
decided to tell him a story about the
first incarnation of show me the funny
which started probably close to 20 years
ago and we had done something somewhat
similar with a group of comedy writers
and then Jeffrey said who would who
would the writers you interviewed and as
I started to name each writer Jeffrey's
I start to go
at this and he said every writer you
named was at my house playing poker with
my dad when I was growing up and then he
literally jumped off the couch and said
let's do the project so it all happened
within that first night so the people
that you've talked to who have come to
you and maybe had questions about their
own partnerships is it that one of the
other side of the partnership is not
following through on details maybe
they're a little flaky is it an
overpowering of egos so many things that
could think that partnership and not
work it's kind of like friendships and
relationships it's like if you said to
somebody well do you find the
relationships no work because people
butter their toast too loudly and scrape
the you know it could be it could be
just about anything I dunno a
partnership that broke up because the
one guy would sit and they'd always work
at his partner's house and he was
picking of picking apart fabric he was
so nervous that he was he and the wife
had just recovered the sofa I mean I'm
sure there were other reasons but that
was part of it
you know that they just got on each
other's nerves so I think that I think
that you have to really have a mutual
respect I what I find with particularly
with young writers is that one person
will let the other person do 95% of the
work and then what 50% of the credit and
that's not gonna work that's kind of
what you were saying that's not gonna
work you know
I expect that in 20 year olds but by the
time you're 30 you better know that
you're gonna have to put and then I also
think you have to sit down and decide
sometimes we've never had to actually do
this decide who is gonna do what we just
sort of comes naturally like I for
example with with the interviews I'll uh
I don't know why this is such a strange
thing Peter absolutely hates
transcribing and in the first book we we
we hired
people to do the transcribing but for
some reason I said well he's doing so
much I'll do the transcribing I kind of
like it I can kind of add it as I do the
transcribing so it takes a little piece
out of the process we don't have to so
as I've gone along I've kind of taken
that on and he takes out other things
but we go I don't recall having major
discussions about it or anything it kind
of what comes naturally to each of us we
have a pretty good ebb and flow in terms
of who's good at what and likes to do
what I try to get him to do more but it
does you know and sometimes it works
he's basically not strong enough we arm
wrestled to decide and the Scorpions
cared left I think we're doing okay is
enormous ly polite I'm going for the
polite hypothesis
you